Alexis is in Indiana
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Alexis
hi how are you doing today Dave better
than I deserve what's up so I got
married in September and my husband and
I realized we have a mound of debt that
I'm not prepared to you is work on and
he is pretty much fine with it
and I am NOT and so I ask you behind the
SPU for Christmas and looking through
things today we have in total sixty
seven thousand six hundred and five
dollars in debt which includes student
language two cars a ring and two credit
cards I'm currently in graduate school
and for school counseling but I'm
wondering if I should leave my job
that's in the education field to go and
make more money doing something not
related to my future career are you
currently a school counselor no I work
as an advisor a public school but I
don't make that much money and what I
could be I make their thirty four
thousand what does your husband like he
makes about forty seven five and he is a
promotion and as soon as a position
becomes available when will you graduate
you from your master's program I will
graduate in May of 2022 whoa ways out
there yes so between now and then if you
worked making more money and then it
shifted back to your career field after
your graduation what would be wrong with
that
my husband's concern is that it might
just not look good and I just started
this job I'm in August and I told him
because it was an education due to
employers if I had changed jobs again
hmm
I don't think employers give a rip okay
that's what I thought
I mean the days of you needing to be on
a job for 30 years to be considered
stable are over people just don't stay
on jobs that long not today so I don't
think that's a concern if you did
something different what could you do
and what would you make my job as a
social worker
because of this job at that I made
almost 41 so I could go back to that or
something to that effect
I've been looking I should try to get an
emergency license and if a position
comes available I would take that
definitely yeah ten thousand dollar
increase in income yes yeah I'll do that
and then you can definitely go back and
be a school counselor with your master's
degree in that or you may take that
master's degree and do something else
with it even by the time you finish in
2022 a lot of different things could
happen and then the two of you roll up
your sleeves are you both going to
Financial Peace University together
after the after Christmas that's the
plan I told him that if he was getting
it for me for Christmas you had to go
yeah that's that's the biggest part of
the gift because you can't go by
yourself if you go by yourself all I'm
gonna do is teach you to be pissed off
at your husband for not doing this stuff
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna make you
unhappy newlyweds and I do not want to
do that I know will drive a wedge
between you if you go and he doesn't so
he has to go with you okay okay okay and
then you guys will do this because
you're gonna be making $80,000 a year
and how quick can you clean up sixty
seven thousand dollars two years yeah
yeah you'll be out of debt and before so
before you finish your masters you'll be
done with your debt
way to go awesome that's exactly the
plan you're doing it very very very cool